The joe rogan experience.
It's not about being a pure tin.
It's not about being anti porn.
It's nothing wrong with the lusting after a woman's tits and a woman's ass.
There's nothing wrong with that.
And there's nothing wrong with a woman wanting to be fucked by a man.
Those are normal things.
They're sublet.
Okay.
And don't let people hijack that movement and try to use it for puritanism.
Cause this is what a lot of people are doing.
Shit,
piss fuck on Cock sucker,
motherfucker and tits.
I'm triggered.
I hope you're triggered to,
yeah,
I mean,
absolutely.
I think that what,
what we're dealing with is an exposure of sexual assault,
exposure of a sexual harassment,
sexual assault,
particularly in the workplace.
You know,
and this is a giant issue for people that have to work alongside men and women.
And they develop these little communities inside these little boxes that we call
offices.
And things get really fucking weird.
And if you have a boss,
it's a piece of shit.
And he's constantly harassing the women that worked there and it becomes a
living hell with them.
This stress they're going through.
I mean,
it is a crime.
You're doing something to those people that work there.
You're,
you're,
you're putting this pressure on them.
You're fucking up their life.
Could you imagine doing,
can you eat?
The last thing I would ever want to do was imposed myself sexually and a woman
who didn't want it.
Right?
While you're a healthy person,
like some people,
it's just about getting to the end goal.
Well,
we've all been drunk,
right?
We've all been on a date or a woman didn't want to have sex and we did and we
pushed the issue.
But,
uh,
you know,
I,
I just can't imagine,
like,
I just never days k,
I don't get that.
She doesn't like you.
Oh,
I'm going to make her go feel uncomfortable.
Like,
what the fuck do you get out of that?
That's just weird.
Well,
there's people that hate the opposite sex.
I mean,
and I say the opposite sex.
I don't mean just men who hate women.
There's women who hate man.
There's people who have associated the opposite sex with rejection and pain and
frustration all of their life.
You look at a guy like Harvey Weinstein,
that is an ugly fat guy,
right?
There's no women who are lusting after him.
It was his power and his money that got him into a position where he could get
some pussy and then having power over all these actresses and then hearing
whether it's Ooma Thurman or whatever,
you know,
famous actress Salma Hayek,
all these superstars who are fighting this guy off in hotel rooms.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
He is a maniac,
but he's a disgusting guy who has no shot at getting someone to appreciate him
physically.
They might like his personality,
but for someone to be physically attracted to him as almost impossible,
right?
I mean,
he's eaten himself into this disgusting shape.
Unless you have a fetish or whatever.
Yeah,
you might just end up getting fucked by job of the hut,
just big fat guy with pockmarked skin shooting loads all over you.
There's no way it makes any sense.
But if you're just going to put you in Ocean's 11 you got to do what you gotta
do.
Well,
you know,
Matt Damon,
what did,
what did Matt Damon say that they were trying to get him out of that new oceans
movie?
Well,
it didn't he say something about there's a key to continuum or something that,
that everything is Harvey Weinstein.
Wasn't that it
don't remember the exact quote,
but it was something along the lines of we have to make a differentiation
between sexual assault and,
and men hitting on women.
What's really interesting is seeing how they're acting,
uh,
about this in France,
in Europe,
a lot of women,
especially older actress.
Did you see stuff that you see that's wild.
I want men to be men and in France,
I mean that they're just France part home.
Uh,
they're just different over there.
This,
there,
they have a different attitude.
The same as Brazil.
My friend Tiago a from Brazil told me once,
he's like,
man,
he goes,
if you're in Brazil,
and he goes,
if you're with a girl,
you don't try to fuck her.
She's like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like you're not even trying to fuck me.
Like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Still get mad at you like,
like they appreciate like in Brazil is a very aggressive,
I have sexually aggressive place.
I,
I have had,
uh,
I'll never forget I was working in comedy club and there was a girl there who
was beautiful and um,
she flirted with me and uh,
well I,
I didn't know if she was flirting with me cause I was just,
she was just beautiful and she talked to me.
So I'm like,
oh right.
And so,
but I wasn't going to make a move at her because I'm,
I'm considering every comedian who comes in,
this club makes a move on this girl cause she's the prettiest girl around.
Right.
So I didn't do anything cause I want to be that guy.
And then I never forget by the end of the week,
it was the last night and she's like,
Hey,
there's a party at my house tonight.
Are you going to come?
And I was like,
oh sure.
Right.
So I went to their whatever,
cut to,
I'm leaving and she goes,
are you fucking kidding me?
And I go,
what?
She goes,
I threw a party just to get you to my apartment and you're going to leave.
And I was like,
Oh really?
You want to?
And so we had sex.
Damn.
She had a beat you over the head with it.
Yeah.
So that's,
so there was a woman who was,
but you didn't want to be the guide that was super aggressive against a girl,
a girl that was like,
Hey,
I just like you.
Yeah.
It was just fun guy to hang out with.
Does everything have to be sex?
And I know every guy in the world hit on her.
You know what I honestly,
I mean,
I don't want to say this because
it's almost like in this day and age,
you got to get to know someone forever before you fuck them.
I mean,
literally forever.
You got trying to fuck my wife the first night we went out.
Good.
Good for you.
And she wouldn't,
uh,
which is probably worked out cause we're still together.
And uh,
but I kept,
I did it in a charming way.
Right,
right.
I would say,
honey,
I,
let me ask you this.
Why did you try to fuck her on the first night?
But it took you five nights for the waitress
because I didn't want to be that guy at the car.
Cause I think cause it's a work environment.
Yeah.
So you're the opposite of a sexual harasser?
I guess so.
I guess now that I look at it that way,
yeah.
Not that I did it.
You're sensitive.
Not that you weren't attracted to her,
you just didn't want to be a dick.
Yeah.
I didn't want to have that reputation of that guy.
And plus there's plenty of women in the audience.
I know there's plenty of women.
Right.
So,
uh,
what I would tell her,
I remember the first night we were together,
I was like,
Hey,
um,
I know,
uh,
I know you're going to say you want me to go home,
but you're going to worry that I'm too tired to drive.
And then I might get in an accident.
So you don't have to say that.
I'll just stay.
That's hilarious.
She's like,
no,
it's okay.
I go,
it's nice of you to say that you're strong,
you're brave.
And I know you're going to worry.
So I'm just staying.
I think I did end up staying,
but we didn't have sex.
Right.
And I like probably two more times,
two more times like that.
But also it's,
you don't really know someone's personality for a long time.
I mean that's part of the problem.
The problem is people have physical needs and they get attracted to each other.
And the next thing you know,
look,
there's been many times in my life where I wound up having sex with somebody who
turned out to be crazy.
And then you know,
you're one,
two dates in you like,
guess she seems cool and next thing you know you're hanging out in a week or two
later and she does something completely fucking insane.
And then the crazy just starts leaking out of her pores and you're like,
oh,
well now what have I done?
I've been tangled myself with some person who knows where I live and expects me
to call them every day and we're going to get together and I have to figure out
a way to back out of this.
And then he tried to back out of it and they get fucking angry at you about,
this is back in the old days when people would actually call you a calling you.
Yeah.
There was no tax messaging back then.
You just pick up the phone if someone starts yelling at you,
or I would just dock them for a while until they found some new guy.
Yeah.